ja herzlich willkommen liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer bei
Phoenix vor Ort aus den Magdeburger
Messehallen zur
europawahlversammlung der AFD da hat es
ja einen Formatwechsel gegeben gestern
hat die AFD hier an gleicher Stelle
ihren Bundesparteitag veranstaltet mit
abendlicher Jubiläumsfeier 10 Jahre AFD
und heute mutiert diese Versammlung
quasi in die europawahlversammlung der
AFD Mittelpunkt steht das Wahlprogramm
zur Wahl zum Europäischen Parlament dem
nächsten Frühjahr und die Aufstellung
der Bundesliste also die Kandidaten auf
der Liste für die Wahl zum Europäischen
Parlament dazu gleich mehr von meiner
Kollegin Katharina kühn ich hatte vor
wenigen Minuten Gelegenheit mit der
Bundessprecherin der AFD mit alles
weiter zu sprechen und ich habe es als
erstes gefragt ob sie sich denn bei
Friedrich Merz und Robert Habeck bereits
bedankt habe für die phänomenalen
Umfrageergebnisse für die die AFD
offensichtlich keinen Finger krumm
machen muss
ja also das könnte so erscheinen also
die Fehler die die anderen machen sind
natürlich eklatant auch die ampelpolitik
unter der die Deutschen zu leiden haben
also die chaotischen
Gesetzgebungsverfahren die tun
natürliche übrigens und natürlich auch
der wackelkurs von Friedrich Merz ich
glaube aber
dass wir immer mehr Wähler überzeugen
können also von vormals Protest
wählertum hin zu
programmwählerturm Namen wir können
immer mehr die weder auch überzeugen von
unseren Positionen und das trägt
natürlich sein übriges bei ihr
Ehrenvorsitzender Alex der sagt das ist
gar nicht das Verdienst der AFD das ist
sind die Fehler der anderen die der AFD
helfen das muss man ganz realistisch
sehen
eben anders so wie es hier gerade schon
beschrieben habe wir können immer mehr
Wähler überzeugen und das sehen wir eben
auch in den Umfragen wir sind ja auch in
den ostdeutschen Bundesländern mit
Abstand schon die stärkste Kraft und
jetzt bundesweit laut Insa bei 22
Prozent aber man muss auch sagen
Umfragen sind auch immer nur einen
Moment Aufnahme also auch da muss ich
sagen das nehmen wir mit Demut ähm auf
und konzentrieren uns weiter auf die
Sachverhalt das heißt in dieser Frage
widersprechen sie ihrem
Ehrenvorsitzenden ausdrücklich nein
überhaupt nicht also ergänzend dazu es
sind nicht nur Protest Wähler wir sind
natürlich
Oppositionspartei aber wir können auch
immer mehr Wähler überzeugen und das
macht eben auch unser Ergebnis in den
Umfragen aus heute beginnt ja der
Europawahl die europawahlversammlung der
AFD sie haben gestern an einem Interview
gesagt die EU sei überhaupt nicht
Demokrat isch legitimiert das sein die
Nationalstaat mit ihren Parlamenten da
drängt sich allerdings die Frage auf
warum die AFD ab heute Mittag mit großem
Aufwand einen mehrtägigen Wahlmarathon
veranstaltet zu Erstellung einer
Bundesliste mit den Kandidaten für das
Europäische Parlament wenn dieses
Europäische Parlament eh nichts taugt
nein also das ist gar nicht die Frage
die Frage ist
ist die EU so aufgestellt dass sie den
Aufgaben der heutigen Zeit gerecht wird
und da sagen wir ganz klar das ist sie
nicht wir brauchen einen
kompetenzrückbau von der Europäischen
Union hin zurück in die Nationalstaaten
wo die gewählten Volksvertreter sind
beispielgesetzgebungsverfahren wir haben
über 90 Prozent der Gesetze die aus der
EU kommen super nationales rechtlich
nationales Recht und damit haben wir
natürlich auch eine Störung der
vertikalen Gewaltenteilung und das ist
etwas was auch aus meiner Sicht und
demokratisch ist was gegen das
Subsidiaritätsprinzip das ist ja der
gründungsmythosen der Europäischen Union
verstößt und da müssen wir einfach an
und deutlich mehr Kompetenzen zurück
verlagern wo die gewählten Parlamente
eben auch sind das ist eben in den
Nationalstaaten aber auch um
direktdemokratische Elemente zu
erweitern heißt Volksabstimmung
durchzuführen über elementare Fragen sie
profitieren ja aber auch von der
Europäischen Union muss man sagen durch
ihren Beitritt zur Europäischen
Parteienfamilie Identität und Demokratie
der fließen jetzt aus dem Europäischen
Parlament jede Menge Fördergelder auch
an die in die afd-parteikassen also gilt
doch die Abwandlung des Sprichwort ist
doch nun ruhig in die Hand beißen kann
aus dem man frisst
nein das bedeutet es nicht der Beitritt
der idee-partei das ist ja auch ein
persönliches Projekt von mir gewesen was
auch hier gestern mit der Mehrheit
beschieden wurde ist elementar wichtig
für die AFD es ist einerseits ein
Zeichen dass wir den Kurs der Idee
Partei mit Stützen eben ein Europa der
Vaterländer auch mit zu fördern und in
ein loseres Staatenbündnis hineinzugehen
als ein überbordendes EU Konstrukt was
übergriffig auch in die Eigentumsrechte
und in die private Planung von
privatpersonenunternehmen eingreift dass
wir das insgesamt zurückbauen und die
kompetenzverlagerungen in die
Nationalstaaten auch forcieren das ist
das Programm der idee-partei kurz
zusammengefasst und das wollen wir auch
mit starken Partnern unterstützen denn
wir brauchen starke Partner in Europa
noch kurz zur Innenpolitik nächstes Jahr
sind drei Landtagswahl in Ostdeutschland
da könnte sein dass die AFD stärkste
Partei und damit stärkste Fraktion wird
aber niemand muss mit ihnen koalieren
wenn sie nicht die absolute Mehrheit der
Mandate erreichen da kann man auch nicht
im Fuß aufstampfen sagen ich will jetzt
in die Regierung die anderen wollen mit
ihnen nicht koalieren das heißt sie
werden also auch weiterhin dort in der
Opposition sein
ja also meine Prognose ist sie haben das
völlig richtig beschrieben so von der
Problematik her oder der Herausforderung
die uns darstellt ich glaube dass sich
der Kurs nicht durchhalten lässt der
weil wir bereits jetzt die stärkste
Kraft sind in ostdeutschen Bundesländern
und wir den Umfragen noch weiter steigen
werden das ist meine Prognose das heißt
man kann eigentlich mit an uns gar nicht
mehr vorbeikommen und man muss sich
damit auseinandersetzen und ich muss ihn
eins sagen dieser Brandmauer Diskussion
und kontaktverbote mit der AFD halte ich
für zutiefst antidemokratisch sie können
sich nicht einfach hinstellen und sagen
mit Millionen von WLAN möchte ich nicht
reden ich diskreditiere die Meinung und
ich möchte mit diesen Leuten nicht zu
tun haben ich habe den Ansatz dass man
grundsätzlich mit jedem reden muss und
sich mit jedem Meinungsbild
auseinandersetzen muss um auch später
vernünftige Kompromisslösung im
politischen Entscheidungsverfahren
herbeiführen zu können wie lange willst
du den Björn höcke noch an Spitze der
AFD belassen ist die Versuchung für ihn
nicht viel zu groß als ab nächstem Jahr
als alleiniger Parteichef die Führung
der Partei zu übernehmen
na gut also ich kenne natürlich Ihre
Fragestellung da also Herr höcke machen
hervorragenden Job als
Landesvorsitzenden an Thüringen ich
unterstütze ihnen da auch im Wahlkampf
in Thüringen wir sind ja jetzt schon in
den Vorwahlkampf
hineingegangen und eine andere
Fragestellung stellt sich jetzt nicht zu
dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt also sie bleiben
Bundesvorsitzende oder
bundessprecherinnen und Lehr
Landesvorsitzender also ich bleibe
Bundesvorsitzende solange mich hier die
Mehrheit der Delegierten wählen und auch
Fraktionsvorsitzende solange mich die
Fraktion wählt das entscheidet ein
Bundesparteitag und das ist Fraktion
es entscheiden bei uns nein eben also es
ist ja schon Antwort genug es
entscheiden hier Partei Tage und
Fraktion
soweit alles weiter im Phoenix Interview
danke dass sie da waren